so they decide to trash belittle and
shame the president and his family
including the first lady making fun of
their accent their intellectual
capability their hair you name it and
they decide to ignore a congressional
subpoena for Department of Justice
documents on the FISA abuse scandal and
the Hillary Clinton investigation so who
are they and who do we blame for the
repeated trashing of the first lady why
is it open season on the first family
who do we blame for the refusal to honor
congressional subpoenas there's only one
group to blame and that group is the
Republican Party how did we get so lost
how is it that these people are so
comfortable so at ease hanging in effigy
the bloody head of our president
laughing about killing him in an
elevator laughing about blowing up the
White House threatening to beat up the
president they criticize the intellect
of our president a Wharton graduate who
got a 30 out of 30 on an acuity test
when they Robert DeNiro
Chelsea Handler Madonna Sean Penn Johnny
Depp never got past the 12th grade they
do it with such ease and no shame why
they do it because they can because
they've learned that there are no
consequences that nothing happens to
them when they do Barack Obama on the
other hand Hillary Clinton and Nancy
Pelosi promote resistance and
obstruction police are told to stand
down and not arrest Hollywood jumps in
trying to brainwash everyone that the
president Republicans and anyone who
believes in law and order is the enemy
while ideological federal judges follow
the narrative as president Trump seeks
to protect us in our border because
Border Patrol agents are swamped they
chant in unison the
he's a racist a fascist they differ as
to whether or not they want their water
protected and in the case of Oregon's
governor Kate brown she refused border
protection and refused to assist other
states three days after she accepted a
large donation from George Soros hey
Kate's a geography primer you weren't
even in the picture take a look at this
map your state isn't on the southern
border where the operation is being
conducted the Democrats are comfortable
doing what they do because they've
learned to wield power like the FBI in
the Department of Justice when they
decided that one of their own would not
be prosecuted like when they prioritize
illegal criminals over American citizens
proudly declaring themselves to be
sanctuary they have learned what to do
when they're in power covering for their
own like allowing a corrupt charitable
foundation which in reality is a
pay-for-play international racketeering
syndicate they've instituted a deep
state shadow government to continue
their agenda even when they're gone from
power and unlike Republicans they've
learned to circle their wagons they're
in lockstep with each other on the
Russia collusion narrative when we all
know the only collusion was the cash
flow of hundreds of millions that went
into Bill and Hillary's corrupt
foundation for our uranium and even
though Democrats lost the House the
Senate and the Oval they're still
running the country with the help of
establishment Republicans and as a
result the Trump's are fair game the
president colluded with the Russians and
must be impeached Milani is an idiot
Ivanka successful clothing line must be
removed from the shelves and Erica's
charity gave more than 98% to help
childhood cancer victims his charity
must be shut down
Donnie takes an innocent meeting
and they say he's committed treason
their hate is vicious and it's real and
as they march proudly in their pink hats
oblivious to the irony of their
deafening silence when their Democrat
president was getting sexual favors from
an intern in the Oval Office while he
was president it's time for the
Republicans to start wielding power
they've got to learn to stop their
namby-pamby spineless finger to the wind
approach to running the country it's
time for Republicans to stop fighting
with each other and start supporting the
president
how can you republicans possibly let the
DOJ the Attorney General and the FBI
Stonewall you put on your big-boy pants
and use a Department of Justice and the
FBI to investigate and prosecute those
who violated our laws and while you're
at it
stop apologizing for our Second
Amendment because this ain't gonna end
well unless and until Republicans get
the guts to wield the power to run our
government the way it's supposed to be
run and that's my open tell me what you
think of my Facebook Twitter and
Instagram page hashtag judge Janine